muitos de vocês podem pensar que o
adoçante é uma alternativa saudável a
Açúcar certo errado mas as evidências
que estão surgindo mostram um Panorama
que pode não ser tão doce assim
recentemente a Organização Mundial de
Saúde a OMS finalmente alertou sobre o
uso de adoçantes incluindo o aspartame a
sacarina a sucralose e até mesmo Steve e
derivados não recomendando o seu uso
para controle de peso ou prevenção de
doenças de acordo com a MS uma revisão
sistemática de evidência sugere que
esses produtos não reduzem a gordura
corporal e o seu uso prolongado pode
inclusive aumentar o risco de diabetes
tipo do doenças do coração
cardiovasculares e mortalidade em
adultos certos adanes artificiais podem
causar problemas no sistema nervoso
alergias e até mesmo risco de
desenvolvimento de câncer US anantes
artificiais como acessulfame de potássio
e sucralose podem até bagunçar o
processo de detox do fígado inibindo a
atividade de uma proteína muito
importante que nos protege contra
toxinas ambientais